Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a post apocalyptic drama film
called “Carbon”. Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in the year 2067
when the earth has turned into a barren land
because of global warming. Oxygen and drinking
water are only available to the wealthy. Because
of the amount of carbon in the air, breathing
out in the open is almost impossible. Houses and
buildings are supplied with partially clean air,
but outside them, people are required to
wear masks to stay alive. A healthy human
will suffocate in about five minutes if they
do not wear a specialized oxygen mask. Oxygen,
which once used to be a basic part of nature, has
now turned into a product. Several million-dollar
companies manufacture artificial oxygen in
bulk and sell it at an outrageous rate.
Since only the rich can afford it, the
government provides oxygen to the poor people
at an affordable price. But such
oxygen is not of the best quality
and can kill you with time. Most humans have
fled to Mars with gallons of oxygen and water
as people on earth become more violent. Among all
kinds of oxygen, natural oxygen which can still
be found in the Himalayas is the most in-demand.
It is sold for millions and is even rarer than
diamonds. A few years ago people were so eager
to acquire oxygen, it caused several murders
and protests. The government has since banned the
exploitation of natural oxygen strictly. Even the
rich aren’t allowed to trade or buy it.
When the smuggling of such oxygen started,
the government implemented a new rule according to
which people aren’t allowed to leave their houses
after 6 pm. Anyone who is seen in a public place
during the curfew will be shot dead immediately.
The protagonist of the movie is a thirty-year-old
man named Random Shukla. He was born in Mumbai,
India in the year 2037. Because of the condition
of the environment, he suffered from heart failure
as soon as he took his first breath. Along with
him, forty-three percent of the infants born
that year suffered from heart failure. They have
been living with the help of an artificial heart
pacemaker until now. Random has to always carry
a bag with a device that is attached to his chest
for the pacemaker to work. He claims that he
has only heard the stories of the green and
blue earth and believes it is just a myth.
The man cannot imagine a world where oxygen
is abundant and water is not a luxury. His job
is to smuggle natural oxygen on a small scale.
Because of the artificial heart, he is allowed
to carry two cans of oxygen everywhere he goes,
which helps him smuggle it. At the beginning
of the movie, Random is woken up in his cell
that he shares with several other workers. The
government announces that the supply of oxygen
to houses will be stopped for a short period
of time in the morning. People are told to wear
oxygen masks even when they are indoors during
that period. It is a regular day for Random
until his associate calls him to a meeting with a client
named Yaqub who is willing to pay them millions
to smuggle two cans of natural oxygen.
On a normal day, someone from the client’s
side comes to pick up the oxygen but since
the security has been tighter these days,
Random has to put his life in danger and go to the
client. He accepts the job instantly for money.
His ultimate goal is to collect enough money to
go to Mars and start a new life. Random and his
associate go to the ruins of a building to meet
Yaqub. He is a gangster and the biggest oxygen
smuggler in Mumbai. The man has connections
all over Mars and supplies the rich with pure
Himalayan oxygen. Random tells him that he has a
license to carry natural oxygen so the job won’t
be difficult for him. Yaqub’s men tear his clothes
to check if he is telling the truth. They are
assured after seeing a blinking device attached
to his chest. The boss offers them ten million
rupees each for the job but Random bargains they
should get at least forty million rupees.
Yaqub, who is still unsure of Random’s potential,
challenges him to a match of arm wrestling.
According to him, a smuggler needs courage more
than a license to close a deal. The match starts
during which, Yaqub takes off his oxygen mask
and makes Random do the same for a fair match.
Soon, Random has trouble breathing and has to
deliberately lose to be able to wear the mask
again. Because he showed courage, an impressed
Yaqub agrees to give him forty million. Now,
Random has to bring two cans of natural oxygen
to the other side of the checkpost and hand it
to a client from Mars named Shah. He has to return
with the money before the evening curfew. If not,
the deal will be considered unsuccessful and
both Random and his associate will be killed.
In the following scene, Random is in the metro
station which is also the checkpoint. He holds
cans of oxygen in his bag which, if checked, will
be exposed as illegal oxygen. Random is hoping
that since he has a license, the security officer
wouldn’t go extra lengths to check the oxygen can.
He is so nervous that he freezes when it is
his turn to go in. Just like he had predicted,
the officer doesn’t check the cans and lets him
go after scanning the license. He even advises
Random to not lose his license or he can end up
in jail for the rest of his life. Sometime later,
he reaches an apartment where the client
Shah is waiting for him. Shah was flown to
Mars when he was only five years old by his
wealthy parents. He survives on high-quality
artificial oxygen which is still not as good
as natural oxygen. Hence, the man is always
keen on buying cans of natural oxygen.
He has recently returned to earth for the same
reason. Random notices a glass full of water
on the table. He cannot help but stare at the
strange sight of clean water which is usually
reserved for wealthy people. Shah offers it to
him which surprises Random. He doesn’t accept
the glass and gets straight to the business instead.
Shah claims that residents of Mars only
return to earth for pleasure or for business,
he is there for the former. Random gets the
hint and brings out the cans of fresh oxygen.
The oxygen was collected and packaged at
eight hundred meters above sea level, making
it non-toxic and a hundred percent pure.
Shah inspects the cans and appears to be impressed
by them. Yet, when Random asks for the payment,
he hesitates. The oxygen might have moisture mixed
in it which means he cannot pay without testing
it first. Random replies that even if the oxygen has
moisture, it is the last batch coming from the
Himalayas. Soon, these kinds will also not be
available for purchase. He suggests the client
use the opportunity wisely but his words make
Shah suspect him even more. As the two get into a
heated conversation, Shah mentions that the earth
is about to shake violently very soon. Just as
he says that the coffee table starts shaking.
Random notices that the table is actually a box
that has something or someone inside of it. The
two do not acknowledge the shaking and continue
the bargain. They do not go on for long before
the box moves again. Random had come to end the
deal without violence but seeing that the client
doesn’t want to pay, he brings out a gun. However,
Shah is not someone who backs up. He, too,
points a gun at Random. While Random is nervous,
Shah appears to be excited. He claims that his
life on Mars was boring and their conversation
is giving him an adrenaline rush.
In split seconds, Random shoots the man on the
forehead and kills him. He had realized that
only one of them could walk away alive, so he took
the only opportunity that he had. Following that,
he opens the box that had been moving
and is surprised to see a girl inside of it.
She is tied up and gagged and seems to have been
kidnapped. Unsure what she is capable of doing,
he points his gun at her as well. The girl freezes
in shock but is relieved when he frees her hands.
Random threatens her to stay low and keep quiet
because he doesn’t want to have to kill her. As they talk,
the girl reveals that the man who Random just
killed is not Shah. The real Shah’s dead body
lies in the bedroom. It turns out that the man
Random was talking untill now was pretending
to be Shah to stall him. He was actually a hitman
who had killed Shah moments before. The girl also
reveals that the hitman was about to smuggle her
to Mars before Random arrived. Random knows that if
he returns to Yaqub without the money, he will
end up dead. Hence, he looks around the house
and finds several gallons of clean water. He
almost doesn’t believe the treasure before him. He
wants to smuggle them out but the containers have
an in-built security system which means if someone
tries to take them out of the building without
a passcode, the police will be alerted.
Right then, it is announced that the
evening curfew has been implemented.
Random’s deal has failed, so he is bound to be
killed if he returns home. He has to quickly think
of a way to run away from the city before Yaqub
finds him. Somewhere else, Yaqub is impatiently
waiting for his arrival. When he is notified that
the curfew is in action, he takes off Random’s
friend’s oxygen mask and eventually kills the
man by suffocating him. Back in the apartment,
Random asks the girl about her true identity. She
introduces herself as Pari and claims that she is
a refugee who was bought by Shah. He planned to
take her to Mars as his mistress. But as soon as
she arrived there, the hitman killed Shah and held
her hostage. As the two talk, Random’s artificial
heart alerts him of overheating. Pari realizes
that she is making him nervous which makes him
blush even more. When asked what she wants to do
now, Pari claims that she will travel the world.
Weirdly enough, she keeps repeating the same thing
as her voice turns more and more robotic. Random
asks her if she is fine and soon realizes that
she is just a robot who has been programmed to
think she is a human. Pari malfunctions and turns
her power off and Random is left all alone.
He plans to run away as soon as the curfew
is lifted. A few hours later, he breathes
in the exclusive oxygen out of curiosity. It
doesn’t go well because the whiff of clean
oxygen makes him pass out. When he wakes up the
next morning, Yaqub and his people are standing
in front of him. They tie him to a chair,
assuming that he killed Shah for the
gallons of water. Random tries to explain what
actually happened but Yaqub doesn’t believe him.
His men do not notice the security system
attached to the water containers and start
to carry them to the elevator. Yaqub leaves
Random tied to a chair so he would be arrested
for killing Shah and the hitman. However, as they
try to walk away with the water, an alarm rings,
alerting the police. Just then, Pari switches on
and unties Random’s hands. The police catch Yaqub
and his gang. Since they only care about
the gallons of water being smuggled,
they do not bother to search for Random and
Pari. In the end, the pair manages to escape
through a secret passage.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.